[Music]
[Music]
today i'm going to present to you a new
perspective to street photography the 14
millimeter wide angle lens in
combination with my new sony film
simulation the kodak ultra max 400 this
new film simulation has become my number
one choice in every situation over the
past couple months and the results keep
on surprising me
for the past three months i've been
researching testing and working on new
film simulations for sony cameras and
they are finally here
some of these film simulations are the
kodak ultra max 400 porsche 400 fuji
classic chrome and the original
kodachrome 64 and many more
these profiles come together with luts
to get you even closer to the original
film look
you can find both the film profiles and
the luts on my website store links down
below
so before we start if you're excited
about these film profiles hit the like
button subscribe and check the
notification bell to be notified of any
upcoming videos
lately i kept seeing street photography
taken with 85 mil lens but i think
that's lazy photography for a number of
reasons first being that you can keep
your distance from the subject and with
that you don't get out of your comfort
zone
it's much easier to build composition
when you have less background to work
with and also because longer lenses
allow you more time to think and compose
while standing in one place and the last
one is debatable with longer focal
lengths you have more subject background
separation and consequently more bokeh
which enhances the aesthetics of the
image but not necessarily the message
you can easily hide flaws and lack of
vision when you have creamy backgrounds
making the image more visually pleasing
that is not the main focus of street
photography to be only pretty at least
not how i see it for me street
photography is about capturing the
present moment sharing feelings and
finding interesting compositions street
photography being a very demanding area
with very little time to find the moment
compose and take the shot it is indeed
the branch of photography that requires
more skill courage and creativity
because you never know what or if
anything will happen
most street photographers use a 35 or 50
ml lens to capture their moments so by
shooting street with a super wide angle
lens you will increase the difficulty
considerably this is a challenge for
most people even experienced
photographers
[Music]
and this will push your skills to the
limits because of the intensity of the
moment i have to be snappier more
calculated and mindful of the present
moment the adrenaline rush that comes
with it becomes sort of an addiction
[Music]
currently i'm in a mental state of
burnout and generally speaking i feel
very depleted of creative energy but
shooting with the kodak ultra max 400
has made the process so much more
enjoyable
the 14 millimeter brings out a new
intimate perspective in street
photography being so wide the necessity
of getting close to the subject it's a
must in 95 percent of situations
creating a very immersive reality
close subjects looking enormous while
distant objects appearing to be miles
away it is a lens that creates tension
by pushing everything into extremes
[Music]
the 14 millimeter definitely has a
dramatic sense to it and it's all about
the subject in its environment
while a 35 or 50 mil will offer a more
isolated and intimate perspective
a super wide angle lens will tell the
whole story of the subject in direct
relation to the surroundings
[Music]
with the wide-angle lens you need to
plan the shoot seconds before happening
if you don't want to miss it
need to get very close very fast when
taking the shot
and when you do this you are more than a
viewer from outside perceiving the
action happening you are taking part in
the story while also influencing it
[Music]
although some shots seem to be taken
from a distance in most occasions i was
very close to the subject sometimes with
a camera right in their face
the intensity of the moment will build
up courage and experience leading to
more skillful decisions in the future
this can get very intrusive and
uncomfortable for some and you should
expect different reactions from people
i've only started doing street
photography with this 14 millimeter
about two weeks ago but i already see so
many improvements in my photography
compared to my first day
[Music]
in this last part it was raining pretty
hard so i felt discouraged but in the
end i decided to go out and try to find
some compositions
[Music]
as expected there weren't many people on
the street but it was very calming to be
alone in the city and feeling the rain
falling on my skin
[Music]
for these shots i went for a cold
sinister tone to get the same kind of
look all you have to do is set the white
balance under 2 500 kelvin i have a
video on this subject called cine steel
800t recipe and i'll put the link in the
upper right corner of the video for you
to watch
[Music]
[Music]
overall shooting with a 14 millimeter
was definitely a challenge which at
times can get frustrating but hey don't
give up
i really did enjoy shooting street
photography with this lens and now
longer focal lengths seem even easier to
manage
you can find all 18 film simulations for
sony cameras on my website and if you
like them you can buy me a coffee or
make a shop purchase to get even more in
return
don't forget about the luts to get even
closer to the film look
so till next time keep shooting have fun
and let us know in the comments what you
think about the new profiles see ya